est ce vous dirai oui oui bonsoir
j'étais sûr que vous alliez me demander
j'ai pas levé la main je voulais parler
sur invitation de ça vous étiez
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qu'on préférait
donc votre ancien ministère oulalala
l'intérieur s'il ya plus de boulot non
bah c'est différent à l'intérieur c'est
le ministère des crises d urgence et ça
aura des choses graves mais importante
aussi ça a été promotion absolument de
ministre délégué à oui c'est ça donc
vous étiez vous étiez contente oui bref
vous êtes la chouchoute de brigitte
macron s'ébroue pas un jeu crysis macro
et de chouchou mais j'ai beaucoup de
respect et d'admiration pour son
engagement d'ailleurs bernard montiel à
l'accompagner je me permets de le dire
je taperai quelque chose chantera me
dirai ce que je peux dire ça va au bout
duquel il a plus eu de réponse à
châteauroux était telle que j'allais
dire je me permettrai pas je crois que
les uv sont fermés avec bernard montiel
on a déjà été à gauche et makoun ont des
engagements notamment justement pour
protéger les femmes face au jeu lensois
je sais qu'il est très engagé aussi sur
ce sujet avec la formation des femmes
exactement et marlène était toujours
présente aussi il faut le dire ce qui ne
va pas son nom cherchez s'ignorent c'est
à dire qu on dirait des choses sans s'en
rendre compte et en fin de compte on ne
on ne ferait pas de mal parce qu'on sait
que vous je crois la guerrière djamel
question
frérot tu as essayé de m'appeler toute
la journée j'ai une gastro de ouf j'ai
pas bien je te jure s'insère très roger
répondre à personne pas sympa sans kaka
mais pour la peine je trouve que ce
maître du chien alors déjà moi j'arrive
pas prendre le contrôle à terme il faut
appâter très fort voire pas du trajet
des hackers marocains qui se sont
beaucoup il se bat dit vas-y vas-y a
déjà commencé
[Rires]
ces normes
les sauterelles et son très fort les
hackers marocains
je crois qu'on n'allait pas de bravo mot
djamel condamne sans
douche mais avec la touche pas à mon
pote
et ce soir je voudrais souhaiter un pas
lundi soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moreau des bandes anniversaire mon chéri
d'amour
merci merci on t'aime fort mon chéri
j'ai tous mes potes du plan tour là et
bon thème rhône et le devenir de cet
endroit-là tellement et demi et un amour
ma chérie tu as décidé de te lancer dans
le fromage exactement le cantal là
dessous avec michel on est assez fines
gueules enfin et on est bien bien manger
un fromage dans l'or puisque je fais un
polonais hollandais belges ont donc
détruit un gars qui est près de
maroilles d'accord précise j'aime
beaucoup de marouane et on a décidé
comme ça ça s'efface lors d'un dîner
mais pourquoi vous prenez pas ça et
michel s'est mis et moi aussi on met la
main ça c'est plus le cantal la tous
avaient tout donné et c'est une
appellation d'origine protégée d'accord
alors est ce qu'on peut en avoir parce
que tu nous en a ramené tout nous a fait
l'honneur de ramener un togolais les
téléspectateurs on va le goûter et voilà
public alors bien entendu il ya les
gestes barrières non merci merci merci
elle que chantal ladesou alors est ce
que vous en pensez
on fouette un bas voilà donc chantal
c'est son fromage le cantal à tout ça
vous plaît mais on dirait que de de
l'anchois dessus ah non non je crois pas
non non non non c'est que ça fait 1 donc
moi je n'ai pas de bons souvenirs bien
sûr c'est une connerie le programme
et personne ne soit pas là dessus et à
gerland choix et mes mots
[Musique]
cette musique est pas l'écouter un
goûter chez vous
[Musique]
le sunshine baujot ordinateur vous
regardez c'est bien sûr sa série b
novelli voilà quatre saisons 16 ans est
avec a pas eu écoles aujourd'hui et qui
va nous donner son avis sur la télé mais
ça va la tenir en mode savate atteinte
et bien pas trop calme tranquille j'ai
pris de l'avancé sur mes devoirs tout va
bien d'accord tout va bien tu as bien
manger doit bien sûr rcg le biplan j'en
peux plus mais ça va d'accord tout cas
très beau témoignage j'ai vu quelqu'un
partir et la sentence a été révocable le
plus grand talent de ces vingt dernières
années
ce talent n'est plus le talent n'est
plus dans incroyable talent
keogh le lavabo a été éliminé regardez
théo qu'on a récupéré vivant maintenant
des chipolatas côté du studio ciné live
et en direct ça va t on à bercy on
entend pas on imagine ce qui fait que la
verrière
là aussi je suis français un accroc est
peut-être je suis français il avait des
idées des numéros qui sont pas du tout
français c'est vrai ça n'a pas de ses
minorités
mais si ses invités laisser parler m'a
laissée par les benjamins après mamie ou
sera tout comme sa tête jean marie le
pen qui représente à l'afrique et la
france
on leur a un bon joueur mais il faut il
faut quartier oui merci oui
[Musique]
je suis
il attend
sa sélection si tu arrives tu à tes
frères ou s'éclater au sol t'amuser et
nous de la bonne musique là c'est ça la
digue
religion
[Musique]
c'est lars cas du moment c'est julien
beat skate avec les biloutes 18 ans qui
t'arrive tu commences à me bats toi
comme en normandie julien benneteau
beyrouth
c'est ça c'est à quel âge j'ai 12 ans -
12 ans aux alentours et c'est un truc de
même âge et c'est un truc de ouf ce qui
t'arrive bah ouais poteau serait on
tenté mon frère autres salades et
montbérault sais pas comment je te kiffe
ben moi aussi je tenais vraiment voix de
roue avec tes yeux parce que neymar a
dit qui rêvait de jouer avec messi déjà
de toute façon mais si ça fait un an
qu'il n'est pas heureux
on va voir ça ouais ensuite neymar ne
peut pas aller au barça parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'argent bas donc il ya une
solution c'est que messi viennent au psg
et donc ça a l'air d'être dans les
tuyaux il offre un confort sans rien que
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire si ça
se fait qu'il appelait mesures en vue
d'appeler nas et allô allô mon acer ces
civils ça va mon acer et toi dis moi mon
acer je suis en vie je suis en direct à
l'antenne
je voulais à te faire un bisou un de
dire tu fais un travail 2 te dire qu'il
fait un travail fabuleux pour la
fondation du psg et 3 que c'est vrai que
messi va venir au psg parce que tu m'as
agité là tu peux pas parler de ça et en
tout cas mais voilà tout cas ce que fait
un gros bisou et si messi bien au psg je
prend 8 abonnement pour des
téléspectateurs et moi d'accord
la chanson on saluera ce que ça lui aura
en profiter après on verra
faut qu'on arrête de nous [ __ ] la
trouille chocolat est
loukas et les couleurs ça passe tout
seul c'est en 90 je me confie sébastien
va mourir à 19 ans dans un accident de
moto et tu as dit que c'est arrivé à
plat la durance total tadieu l on entend
de l'afrique la pire phrase du monde
pour toi est ce que vous voulez venir
reconnaître le corps de votre fils à la
morgue
ça c'est un truc c'est la pire phrase
que tu peux entendre dans ta vie c'est
sûr ça sera la pire phase il peut me
dire n'importe quoi comme insulte
aujourd'hui ça sera jamais aussi violent
que ça patrick mongil s'imposer parce
que mes temps que la femme non plus tout
à fait pour revenir à l'antenne
est ce que tu es venu tout de suite à
l'antenne après non mais je suis monté
sur scène tout de suite le soir parce
que c'est une question de survie
et moi j'ai eu une chance extraordinaire
j'avais un public qui vous donner de
l'amour à qui josé de l'amour mais je
pense à tous ces gens qui perdent
quelqu'un et qui ont personne à côté
parce qu'il faut quand il faut pas
s'écrouler par terre au contraire forest
faut rester debout
[Musique]